if you asked me what scares me more
having way too much or having way too
little it's having way too much
[Music]
who turned you into this guy did
something to America and my mother you
know I was born in the Soviet Union I
didn't come up with much so adversity
America my mom and my dad because when I
was 14 and started working my dad's
liquor store for 2 bucks an hour I was
so full of [ __ ] and he sucked it out of
me over 10 years cuz he hates lying and
[ __ ] and so he scared me I was
scared to embellish let alone lie I
don't get upset when people like you
know this guy's full of [ __ ] yeah
because I'm like I understand I actually
had that in me but my dad systematically
took it out and I think it comes from
lack of entitlement is entitlement a
disease a hundred I'm scared shitless of
properly raising my children cuz you're
gonna have so much listen straight up
and I know the audience I know the
culture I get it it's great up if you
ask me what scares me more having way
too much or having way too little it's
having way to where too much a hundred
percent because that person but is
suicidal and depressed abundance yeah
but people can't you can't see happiness
there's so many people I know that make
forty thousand a year and love life and
so many people I know that have forty
million in the bank and hate life and
everybody's saying like cool I'll take
my chances I'll be 40 million I get it
but guess what
that's what the forty million person
saying to like damn I wish I mean wasn't
born into this trust fund people aren't
listening and the reason I talk about
materialistic things
it is the band-aid and the makeup of
unhappiness for ninety five percent
they're trying to impress people they
don't even like you've seen a bunch of
people come through here yeah right
people come through here when they were
just starting their careers or two years
later they popped they came in here
you're about to figure out exactly who
they are
where did the same person they walked in
here 19 months ago yeah some do and they
leave and you're like yo thank god
that's good people yeah and sometimes
you come in here and they forgot have
you learned from hip-hop have you
learned anything from sitting down with
nipsey would like yeah but but what I
learned from hip-hop or or the culture
happened a long long time ago it
happened in Edison New Jersey but it
really really happened in Newton
Massachusetts I went to Mount Ida
College from nine
for 298 it was you know 96% minorities
it was 95 percent of them on financial
aid I learned a lot because I was deep
in it I didn't visit my friend in the
hood for a day for four years I lived
deep in it yeah and and that's when I
got a sense of it and what it taught me
that that half decade was oh this is
this exact is there anybody in hip-hop
that's that's not utilizing this
opportunity that they have all of them
really know but nobody's squeezing it
hard enough what are they not doing they
don't realize how valuable the attention
is right now on social media like
they're sitting on their music put your
music out if the Internet is where
people's attention is you got music
posted on Instagram right now your mind
followers started everybody thinks you
need a million followers what if you're
one follower is you it's not about how
many it's who and what can they do if
you got SoundCloud and Spotify and
Instagram and YouTube guys T grizzly
comes out of [ __ ] jail after nine
five four and a half years yeah from
being locked up for a half decade to
putting out one [ __ ] video and a song
if you've got talent this is about
Talent sure and all of a sudden 72 hours
later twenty-one Savage is DMing you so
if you've got flames and you've got bars
and you're [ __ ] so great put it out
but what's happening is people are
insecure of course people are
overthinking [ __ ] people are artists
trying to make it perfect sure it's ego
it can be that the internet and social
media can be a curse because they just
come after yeah but when you can't hear
them but when you can't hear them it
doesn't matter when you get to that
place when you can't hear them then you
start making content then you start
living your life for real it's just like
high school I'm going to be getting into
high school you're worried about
everybody's opinion but they kind of by
senior year you got your clique yeah I'm
just trying to get everybody in real
life to get to the place they were in
high school the last month of high
school it comes back to self-awareness
my god there is no one path the only
path is like do you know yourself and
more importantly that voice inside your
own head a lot of times people to
understand that that was put in your
head a lot of people when I'm like don't
listen to anybody but yourself
I'll get that DM they're like yo I love
that my problem is I'm telling myself I
suck and I'm not have to DM like yo you
didn't like that isn't you that's your
mom or dad that put that in your head
and now you believe it and you think
it's your own voice nobody starts off
thinking they suck here's the problem
and I'm not trying to be mean I'm trying
to make you happy and win most of the
people listen right now don't have the
talent and that is okay okay and me by
the way some of the cats in this room
probably when you guys were seven eight
nine ten eleven might have thought you
wanted to be the artist yes but and what
I would say is kudos to you to be like
yeah look that you understood that that
what you are gonna be you know Queen
Latifah that's it you know what I love I
love perspective
if you're listening to this right now it
means you have the ability to listen to
this right now which means you live in
America it means that you have some sort
of device that allows you to listen to
this I just don't think people
understand how lucky they have it no
matter how shitty they think they have
it Gary I read somewhere that
Millennials don't want to be told what
to do but they all need to be told what
to do
listen I'm so tired of old people
judging Millennials when they're the
ones who [ __ ] raise these Millennials
while we talk about the parents that
raised the Millennials our fiddle that
created the entitlement Shore who didn't
want their kids ever crying who wanted
their kids to be in in games where 8th
place trophies happen and then number 2
like here's my thing
it doesn't matter what that report says
I know a ton of Millennials that bleed
other eyes 19 hours a day and want it
it's funny we've gotten real
politically-correct about not being
prejudiced about you know skin color or
male or female right but we're [ __ ]
on Millennials as a whole and I think
it's totally unacceptable and I want to
remind everybody just because you put
entrepreneur in your Instagram title
right and you went and printed eight
t-shirts that came up with some word
that is now your brand doesn't mean
you're a successful entrepreneur I can
put basketball player in my [ __ ] bio
I play ball guess what I don't get paid
there's a big difference between being
an entrepreneur and being a successful
entrepreneur I believe in optimism right
but if you don't back your optimism or
manifestation with [ __ ] work and
smarts like nobody you know nobody you
know ever made it you know without
putting in the work from 15 to 30 I
didn't go anywhere on the weekends
nowhere who did that who worked 18 hours
a day for a [ __ ] 15 years like I did
then you who left college on Friday
afternoon to take a [ __ ] Amtrak down
and not even the Acela stop in every
which way on the East Coast to then and
then get into Jersey Woodbridge train
station and then drive to the liquor
store work two hours then go home sleep
for six and the work all day Sunday and
then wake up all day Saturday for 13
hours in that liquor store then wake up
Sunday right and go back to Boston to go
back to school
Oh Gary me you don't know me sure I
[ __ ] worked every minute my life how
do you find your balance from working
and life I guess I love them so much you
know like I love them both so much like
I do what I need to do so I think people
are just letting other people's opinions
so like work-life balance real easy
I do what I want and as long as the five
to nine people I give a [ __ ] about the
most are cool with it then I'm good I'm
not a motivational speaker that wants
you to pay me $5,000 to be your coach I
don't want your money
I don't want anything super shots fired
super shots fired when people say they
want to change your life but real quick
give me six thousand to do it you're not
changing [ __ ] I'm chasing admiration my
guy that's right you know what
admiration feels like like if anybody's
got it out there if you from one person
your little nice you know like so many
admiration like do you know what I felt
like coming in here today so good taking
picture with her in front like that's
nice about my new how to make money I
know how to make money I don't need the
people watching me on the gram or
YouTube or my podcast to give me their
money I've always known how to do that I
want your [ __ ] admiration my guy gave
you here my guy Mike I appreciate oh my
god oh my god oh my god thank you my man
thank you so much for having me you
serious my guy
I appreciate it you are my guy my god
how do you I appreciate that
[Music]
you
[Music]